I like to think of the London
Underground as being like the
veins and arteries
of the capital.
Subterranean plumbing that's
taking everybody where they
need to go.
Even the timetable feels
like a pulse.
Our hearts pump the nutrients
that we need in order to
survive around our body--
sugars, fats, the amino acids
that are the building blocks
of proteins.
But it's not all good though.
It also takes cholesterol.
Now, we all need a bit of
cholesterol, we use it in our
cell membranes.
But too much of it
can be dangerous.
Low Density Lipoprotein, or
LDL as it is known, is a
particularly dangerous
form of cholesterol.
It can build up in our
arteries, leading to
cardiovascular disease,
a leading cause of
death in this country.
A gene in chromosome 19 codes
for the LDL receptor, a
protein that binds LDL and
takes it out of the
bloodstream.
If you've got something wrong
with this gene then you
develop familial
hypercholesterolemia, this
means that the cholesterol stays
in the arteries and can
lead to cardiovascular
disease.
It's like when the escalator is
broken, people can't leave
the station fast enough.
And so congestion starts to
build up, and congestion can
lead to trouble.
When the blood can't flow,
the body starts to die.
My father has genetically high
cholesterol, but he knows
about it so it's no big deal.
He just has to watch what he
eats that bit more carefully
than the rest of us.
Forewarned is forearmed.
If we understand how our genes
and our body work, then we can
avoid any trouble.
I think this weekend I'm just
going to take the bus instead.